my guest this week is an author a
speaker and a one-woman show that's
something right her new book Carlin Home
Companion tells her journey growing up
as the daughter of George and Brenda
Carlin she's also my friend and throws a
hell of a party
Kelly Carla and welcome to the show I'm
so excited to be here this is so
fabulous doesn't it seem more mature
than anything we've done here so
grown-up right now this is kind of
scaring me this is very grown-up before
we start you just pointed to our I
wasn't like window note at so this this
picture in case now I know we're blowing
the illusion yes sorry television but
that is a picture it's not an actual
window that is the Upper West Side
that's 89th Street okay sing north all
right and just a little bit past where
this picture ends is actually just in
the last year a street that is now named
after your father this isn't where I was
intending to start with but let's start
there your dad now is a street yes he
has officially a street at 120 first and
Amsterdam we wanted it to be between
Broadway and Amsterdam but there's and
that was the block he grew up on yeah
but there's also a church there the
church his mother attended the church
that that had the school that he
attended as a child he was kicked out of
that dirt right was or he was out of the
school kicked out of the school and then
he was allowed to come back to graduate
for eighth grade but he had to write the
play in order to get back in which they
were great it was actually a very
progressive school for a Catholic school
but the irony is is that once we wanted
to name the street the church um got all
up in arms about it worried I well they
claimed that they were worried about
kids coming out of school and looking up
and seeing the name and then googling it
and finding out about the seven dirty
words that was their concern right also
not a huge fan of religion I'm guessing
they're more worried about the religion
is correct video that they
would probably find on YouTube yeah I do
there must be 50 of their there is
probably as yeah we're working on that
we're trying to you know organize all of
that but but yeah but you can go to
121st and Amsterdam on the other side of
the street and there is George Carlin
when
a right so just to be clear they lit so
it's on the same Street Street but they
just pushed it one block yeah they just
put it across the street on Amsterdam
because I mean it's it's once again it's
one of those just the thing a churches
have these lines that they draw and
they're ridiculous but the good news is
was that when all this went down was it
got us so much press that it ended up
being like a kind of a funny thing they
actually got us more attention for the
street sign that I think they probably
would have won yeah although every comic
in the world wanted to be there that day
and you had a zillion yeah I was it was
an amazing day and Kevin martini the
comic he's the one who initiated it and
did it all but yeah we had Colin Quinn
and Dave Attell and just you know it was
it was a great day yeah well I love the
fact that what I'm putting right here
this we did this because I used to live
on the Upper West Side so it's a nice
it's a nice way to I feel at home yeah
so as I said in my intro one of the
things that I that I love about having
you here and we've been doing this kind
of stuff forever but one of the reasons
that I think it's particularly apropos
now beyond just your book is that all of
the things that your dad's stood for I
think are really coming to fruition
right now there's something again again
right it's a cyclical thing yeah it's
like this endless thing but I feel like
there's a moment now between religion
and political correctness and free
speech these things that he railed on
more than anybody and did better than
anybody they're all coming back right
now so before we get into that yeah
let's let's do something a little bit
we'll give him a little hint from the
book give me something about your dad on
the private side because this is someone
who talked about culture not necessarily
talked about himself yeah let's just do
a little yeah he was one of those comics
which really didn't come to me until he
died really but that who really did
focus on I mean he focused on he talked
about three things he focused on the
little things that we all share so that
was the observational humor stuff and
the refrigerator man and the airline
announcements is things like that he
focused on language which is another
thing that we all share as a culture and
then he like would go after the big
subjects death religion children things
like that but he never he
he mentioned me once in a routine in
like 1971 yes one of the earlier albums
where I was very excited he was talking
about what euphemisms for you know
we call it number two and P is number
one and how once I figured that out I
made funny combinations up and things
like that right and that was the only
time I was ever talked about and for
comics yeah you know 99% of the time
their material is their family and their
personal life so my dad was very
different than that and he didn't and he
wrote a memoir but we he didn't publish
it until we published it after he died
yeah so um what do you think that was
about because he so got into the mind he
so got into the very bit of us that we
all share and yet that part he did keep
with that out of respect maybe to your
mom or to your family or no I I don't
know I think I think his mind just
didn't travel there
his mind was out here and that's just
the way his focus was and uh so and it
was kind of weird because I would
growing up I would see other comedians
talking about their families and it did
hit me a few times especially like
teenage years like why did he ever talk
about us on like the tonight I mean I
remember one time he went on The Tonight
Show with Carson as the host and Carson
asked about his family and he had these
funny made-up sons that he talked about
d'Artagnan was one of them which I mean
it was a great bit yeah but I do feel I
already know I've already felt a little
invisible yeah therefore I felt even a
little more invisible at that time yeah
um and yet I think I'm happy about it
because I wasn't my life wasn't fodder
for his comedy whereas my poor dad our
life together has become fodder for my
art so which was a bone of contention
for us and I and I do talk about that in
the book and and not so much as artists
but that there were some things that we
had never talked about as a family that
I really was willing to talk about on
stage like people like Spalding Gray
and you know Sandra Singh Lo and these
other solo artists did you know they go
and comedians yeah I mean I think a lot
of comedians are way more comfortable
going on stage talking about their life
there than having to go home and having
a serious conversation sure but they
left yours yeah well we'll get to the
sad clown thing in a look what you don't
address that you do address that in your
one-woman show that we heard of a
lead-up to the book that there there's a
sort of beautiful moment where you and
your dad are talking and he sort of
there was like a little bit of sense of
betrayal or a sense that he was going to
be exposed in a way that he hadn't done
yeah and I think ultimately I mean what
happened was I wrote a solo show and I
set him the script and inside the script
I talked about having some feelings some
negative feelings about when my mother
was dying and he had to go on the road
and it was a conversation my dad and I
had never had and we didn't have any
real healthy conversation closure around
it but and I and I looking back on it
now I think sending him that script was
my way of saying hey I have these
feelings right but this was one of the
themes I wanted to work on in the book
was that here's this man who is the
truth teller
like you said opening the show I mean
this is the man who conquered everything
was fearless and would talk about all
the big stuff that our culture does not
want to talk about on stage and yet when
it came to our family we were very much
the textbook dysfunctional alcoholic
family that did a lot of walking on
eggshells didn't do a lot of intimate
talking about the issues and we all
pretended that we were fine you know we
all walk so the true all-american family
truly and that everybody and that's like
when people talk about my book and
they're like you know you're such a
unique life I'm like yeah kind of not I
mean I did yeah but kind of like the
all-american family yeah all right so I
don't want to delve too deep it because
I want people I want people to buy the
bus of course so that so that's an
important business but just one more
thing on that did you have a sense when
you were growing up you know your dad
look there were there were drug things
that you talked about in the book and in
the show arrests you know he was he was
arrested the night that Lenny Bruce was
arrested right is that yeah that was
before I was born
right
but these kinds of things that were
going on he was on the front lines so
they say how much of that did were you
conscious
especially in your early years that your
dad really was this this legend I mean
when there's the Mount Rushmore comedy
it's you know half the people say it's
your dad
half the people say it's Pryor and then
maybe there's one percent that gets
split amongst Lenny Bruce in a couple of
yeah well I mean I think the legend kind
of Rushmore thing really happened more
when I was in my 20s and I was at a an
English class at UCLA and my professor
says you know we're going to study a
compare and contrast essays today and I
have a perfect example of how you should
go about this and he pushes the play
button on a boombox and my dad's
baseball football routine comes out and
I'm sitting there in this class of like
25 people looking around going is anyone
else having this weird experience it for
me about what else is bad maybe I mean
yeah that's when you realize oh yeah big
dent in the culture has happened here
yeah um so you know I think it was from
that point on that I knew like legend
but even before that I knew that he was
obviously famous and people worshipped
him and and all that kind of stuff and
and was around for you know an arrest or
two of his also so I knew he was
definitely on the front lines of
something
you